-♪ Wheel of
Musical Impressions ♪
[ Beeping ]
[ Laughter ]
-Christina Aguilera doing
"The Wheels on the Bus."
-Okay.
-Christina Aguilera doing
"The Wheels on the Bus."
Roots --
♪♪
-[ Chuckles ]
[ As Christina ]
♪ The ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
♪♪
♪ The wheels ♪
♪ On the bus go ♪
♪ They go round and around
and, ooh, oh ♪
♪ They go ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
♪ Round ♪
♪ They go round
and around, hey ♪
♪ Wheels on the bus ♪
♪ They go ♪
♪ Round, round ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ They go ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
♪♪
♪ Round ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ha.
♪ Round ♪
♪ Ooh ♪ Ha.
-[ Laughing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ As Sting ] ♪ I can't feel
my face when I'm with you ♪
♪ But I love it ♪
So much!
So do you!
♪ I can't feel my face
when I'm with you ♪
♪ But I love it ♪
Come on!
-Oh, oh, wow.
Oh, no.
Okay, got it.
♪ Se-- ♪
[ Laughs, mutters ]
[ As Michael Jackson ]
♪ Sunny day ♪
♪ Sweeping the clouds away ♪
♪ On my way
to where the air is sweet ♪
♪ Oh, just tell me how to get ♪
♪ How to get to Sesame Street ♪
♪ Oh-oh ♪
-Oh!
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ As Eddie Vedder ]
♪ Do you know the Muffin Man ♪
♪ The Muffin Man,
the Muffin Man ♪
♪ Do you know the Muffin Man ♪
♪ That [Mumbling] ♪
-♪ The Muffin Man,
the Muffin Man ♪
-♪ Do you know the Muffin Man ♪
♪ [Both mumbling] ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ As Britney ] ♪ This little
piggy went to the ma-arket ♪
♪ This little piggy
stayed home ♪
a-ate roa-oast beef ♪
♪ Went "whee whee"
all the way home ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[As Cher] ♪ The best part
of waking up ♪
♪ Is Folgers
in your cup ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[As John Legend]
♪ I don't wanna grow up ♪
♪ I'm a Toys "R" Us kid ♪
♪ Got a lot, a million toys ♪
♪ That I can play with ♪
♪ I don't wanna grow up ♪
♪ Baby, if I did ♪
♪ I couldn't be
a Toys "R" Us ♪
♪ K-i-i-i-i-i-i-id ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ Toys ♪
[ As Jennifer Hudson ]
♪ On top of spaghetti ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ All covered with
cheeee-ee-ee-aaah ♪
♪ I lost my poor meatball ♪
♪ When somebody
sneeeeee-aaaaaaahhh ♪
♪ Rolled off the table,
onto the floor ♪
♪ And then my poor meatball
rolled out of the door ♪
♪ On top of spaghetti ♪
♪ All coveeeeeeeeeered ♪
♪ With cheeeeeeeeee-aaaaaahhhh ♪
♪ Oh, oh, yeaaaaah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ As Christina Aguilera ]
♪ Heeeeeyyyyyy ♪
♪ Who lives in a pineapple ♪
♪ Under the seaaaaaa ♪
♪ Oh, Spongebob ♪
♪ Squarepants ♪
♪ Absorbent and yellow ♪
♪ As porous is he ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ Spongebob ♪
♪ Squarepants ♪
-Oh, my goodness!
Oh!
-♪ Squaw ♪
♪ Twinkle twinkle little star ♪
♪ How I wonder what you are ♪
♪ Up above the world so high ♪
♪ Like a diamond
in the sky ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Fetty Wap!
-[ As Cher ]
♪ Frére Jacques ♪
♪ Dormez-vous, dormez-vous ♪
♪ I don't wanna hear you
ding-dang-dong ♪
♪ I don't wanna hear
a ding-dang-dong ♪
♪ I don't, no ♪
-[ Laughing ] Oh!
♪ Don't need you anymore ♪
-♪ I don't need you anymore ♪
♪ Oh, I don't need you anymore ♪
[ As Sia ] ♪ Hush, little baby,
don't say a word ♪
♪ Mama's gonna buy you
a mockin' bir-bir-bir-bird ♪
♪ And if that
mocking bird won't sing ♪
-[ Laughing ]
-♪ Hush, I'm gonna buy ♪
♪ You a diamond riiiiiing ♪
♪ A diamond riiiiiiiiii-iiing ♪
♪ Ah ♪
♪♪
♪ Like the mirror
doesn't exist ♪
♪ Like it doesn't exist ♪
-Sia!
Oh, my God, Sia!
-♪ Hey! ♪
-Sia! [ Laughs ]
-[ As Ariana Grande ]
♪ Skidamarinky, dinky, dink ♪
♪ Skidamarinky doo ♪
♪ I love you ♪
♪ Skidamarinky dinky dink ♪
♪ Skidamarinky doo ♪
♪ I love you, babe ♪
-What?! Come on!
-[ As Lorde ] ♪ Baa baa black
sheep, have you any wool? ♪
♪ Yes, sir, yes, sir,
three bags full ♪
♪ One for the master,
one for the dame ♪
♪ One for the little boy
who lives down the lane ♪
♪ Baa baa black sheep,
have you any wool ♪
♪ Yes, sir, yes, sir,
three bags full ♪
-[ As Adele ]
♪ A, B, C, D, E, F, G ♪
♪ H, I, J, K, L-M-N-O-P ♪
♪ Q-R-S-T, U, V ♪
♪ W, X, Y, and Z ♪
♪ Now, won't you come
sing it with me? ♪
♪ Now I know my ABCs ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ As Janis Joplin ]
♪ Oh, come on ♪
♪ Come on, come on ♪
♪ Come on and twinkle ♪
-♪ Twinkle ♪
-♪ Twinkle, twinkle, twinkle,
twinkle little star, now, baby ♪
-♪ Twinkle ♪
-Tell me, tell me ♪
♪ How you wonder
what you are, yeah ♪
-♪ Oh, oh, twinkle ♪
-♪ Up above the world
so high, now, baby ♪
♪ You're like a diamond ♪
♪ Ahhhhhhhhhhhhh! ♪
-♪ Twinkle ♪
-♪ Twinkle, twinkle, twinkle,
little star, now, baby ♪
-♪ Oh-hoh, twinkle ♪
-[ As Bob Marley ]
♪ Hush little baby ♪
♪ Don't say a word ♪
♪ Papa's gonna buy you
a mockingbird ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ And if that mockingbird ♪
♪ If it won't sing ♪
♪ Papa's gonna buy you
a diamond ring ♪
-Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Oh, papa's gonna
buy you a diamond ring ♪
♪ Say the word, papa's
gonna buy you a diamond ring ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ As Frank Sinatra ]
♪ The itsy bitsy spider ♪
♪ Came up the waterspout ♪
♪ Down came the rain ♪
♪ And washed that spider out ♪
♪ Out came that crazy sun ♪
♪ Hey, and dried up
all that rain ♪
♪ And the itsy bitsy ♪
♪ Kooky ring-a-ding
little spider ♪
♪ Climbed up that spout
ag-a-a-a-a-ain ♪
-Yes! [ Laughs ]
-Yeah!
Ohh!
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ As Gwen Stefani ]
♪ Three blind mice ♪
♪ See how they run ♪
♪ They ran on
after the farmer's wife ♪
♪ Who cut off their tails
with a carving knife ♪
♪ Did you ever see
such a sight in your life? ♪
♪ As three blind mice ♪
Three blind mice!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ As Bjork ]
♪ Rock-a-bye, baby ♪
♪ On the mountain top ♪
[ Applause ]
♪ When the wind blows,
the cradle will rock ♪
♪ When the bough breaks
on the mountain top ♪
♪ I live in a cradle
-Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Happy Halloween.
-Melissa Villaseñor!
[ Cheers and applause ]